despite duarte's warmth and the genuine
friendship he showed if anything
happened to the laconian ruler he would
be executed shortly thereafter tying
paulo's safety to his own was how duarte
could guarantee the scientists best
efforts on his behalf they both
understood this and there was no ill
will attached paolo's death wouldn't be
punishment exactly just a clear
disincentive to letting his patient die
as relationships went it was probably
the most honest one paulo had ever had
hey guys pete here today i have an
expanse video where i thought i'd
preview the events that happen in the
final trilogy of books that come after
season six i want to do that without
spoiling the end of the story because if
you've enjoyed the tv show then you're
bound to enjoy the books and therefore i
think you should read them although i
will be spoiling what happens in between
the end of the show and the beginning of
the trilogy including the first few
chapters of book 7 persepolis rising i'm
doing that so i'll have something to
talk about but also because those are
available to read free through the look
inside feature on amazon so you can go
ahead and do that first if you want to
and with all of that out of the way
let's get into it
right up front i want to say that i'm of
the opinion that the series has a
satisfying ending i really enjoyed it
and there's probably some recency bias
involved in this but i do think that the
final three books are the expanse at its
best that wouldn't be possible without
what came before but the series didn't
fall off at all it's the kind of ending
that the internet high mind was mostly
able to put together before the final
book came out that led to some criticism
from the super engaged about it being
predictable but overall it seems that
most people would agree that they
managed to deliver an enjoyable
conclusion they do answer a lot of the
questions that readers had been
speculating about and it gives each of
the characters we've been following for
so long endings that make sense you do
find out a lot more about the gate
builder civilization you get some
insights into their history more about
how they use the proto-molecule and more
about the things that they left behind
it's all presented in an interesting way
where i don't even think you have to
fully understand what's going on with
them to enjoy the way things play out
the unknown aggressors remain somewhat
more mysterious but that's mainly
because they're so alien that they're
kinda beyond our comprehension but you
do learn enough to tie that part of the
story together ty frank has said that he
looks at the nine books as being three
duologies in a trilogy books one and two
go together with the proto-molecule
being discovered and the effect that
that has books three and four are the
ring gates opening and us going through
them and books five and six cover the
war that breaks out as a result of
everything that happened in the first
four books seven through nine are when
things loop back to the protomolecule
aspects since humanity does in fact
start using the ringgate network to
reach the stars the books also do a lot
of genre hopping the authors have said
that book one was a noir detective story
with horror elements book two was a
political thriller book three was a
haunted house story and book four is a
western i would say that books five and
six are a disaster story in a war story
and daniel abraham has referred to the
last three as their epic fantasy trilogy
and he made the distinction that it
wasn't lord of the rings of course it's
all wrapped up in a character-driven
space opera and you might not have even
noticed the genre shifts from watching
the tv show but with the addition of
laconia and their continued meddling
with the proto-molecule there are some
major changes going on that increase the
stakes in the final three volumes and
that does give the trilogy a different
feeling
the big surprise at the beginning of
book 7 is that 30 years have passed
since the transport union was founded in
that time things were pretty quiet
compared to the years leading up to the
war with the free navy earth slowly but
surely started to recover from the
asteroid attacks mars settled into its
diminished role in the system and
several of the new colonies beyond the
ring started to thrive the crew of the
rossi enjoyed uneventful prosperity with
plenty of work available for a gunship
and this quiet stretch in their history
is why the authors decided not to write
books to fill in this time period there
could have been another trilogy in
between but the big story wouldn't have
moved much and i think they made the
right decision to skip it of course alex
is still alive in the books he gets
married and divorced again in this gap
and has a son who's not really in his
life bobby and clarissa become permanent
crew members the latter's health
continues to get worse because of the
black market mods that she got to try to
kill holden but she's still hanging in
there and at the beginning of persepolis
rising holden and naomi are thinking of
retiring i guess i should mention that
aging has changed in the expanse's
timeline if you think about it from the
camp to the beginning of book seven
about 40 years have passed not everyone
is exactly the same age but that does
put everyone around their 70s what you
have to keep in mind is that due to
advances in science and medicine
lifespan has increased and anti-aging
drugs are something that everyone takes
on average on earth people live into
their 120s and a 70 year old resembles a
40 year old in our timeline everyone on
the crew is much older but they're still
not what we would consider aging and
i've seen that some people don't like
this time jump for that reason because
they're older but i think it was
absolutely necessary for the story
things needed to develop and i think it
adds another dimension to the characters
which i really appreciate they've been
through a lot they've seen a lot their
youth has passed but they're still
completely capable and they have to deal
and adjust just like we all do i
mentioned that the inner planets haven't
regained their position in the decades
after the war and where the big changes
have happened are in the belt and beyond
the transport union has been successful
and has improved things for belters
there were three massive void cities
built these are essentially settlements
where two hundred thousand or so people
live that can also act as battleships
the void cities and medina station are
the jewels of the belt which now holds
real power due to its role coordinating
things with the colonies through the
ring space there are more than 1 300
systems with habitable planets and over
80 developing colonies that are named in
the books these only account for a
fraction of the total activity going on
so it should be clear that humanity is
in a much different situation than it
was 30 years prior they're spread out
and everything is connected through the
ringgate network one thing that might be
confusing if you jumped right into book
seven after watching the show is that
the book version of drummer is the
president of the transport union it
might feel like carrichy was running
things the whole time this is not the
same character that holden handed things
over to in the season six finale that
was the first president who was named
michiopan in the books and this version
of drummer is the fifth poss served and
got things rolling and then didn't play
a vital role in the rest of the series
at the beginning the ring to laconia is
still closed off they were one of the
few colonies that were able to reach
self-sufficiency right from the start
and as you can imagine they've not been
idle in the decades that passed book 7
opens with the prologue from paulo
cortizar's point of view and in that you
get an idea of how laconia plans to
shape the events in the final trilogy
they have been actively experimenting
and working with the proto-molecule in
that time and have managed to avoid most
of the pitfalls experienced by their
predecessors
winston duarte holds the position of
absolute military dictator of the entire
system and in the three decades since
the breakaway fleet had passed through
the laconia gate they've built up a
little civilization it's based on a
military culture focused on discipline
and dedication to this cause which
amounts to an updated dream of mars
duarte believes he's the right person to
lead humanity into the next chapter of
its existence and only worries about
what might happen when he can no longer
do that in the prologue you learn that
he has a plan to solve that issue and of
course they are also now ready to return
through the ring and introduce their
ideas to the rest of humanity things
escalate accordingly from there and one
more time the crew of the rossi find
themselves in the middle of things early
in the trilogy you learn that laconia
has achieved their technological
advantage and that the problems that
marco and the free navy cause for the
inner planet set the stage for them to
be unprepared for what they're up
against and i suppose that's what there
is to say about the setup the scale of
the story is expanded and even though
they understand how to avoid having
ships getting eaten by transiting the
rings they happen upon other ways to
agitate the unknown aggressors the crew
do get split up again and not all of
them make it out alive some old
characters return and of course some new
ones emerge as one of the only people
that experienced the bullet on ellis
elvi akoya plays a prominent role and
cara and zan and the strange dogs also
return to play important roles of their
own the gate builder tech they found on
laconia is crucial to their development
but it's not the most interesting thing
that was left behind that distinction
goes to a giant diamond structure the
size of jupiter and the adros system
which is empty otherwise when they
encounter and study that for the first
time they wonder if it might not be a
backup drive containing the memories of
the gate builder hivemind so things get
interesting and weird and as i mentioned
earlier you do learn a lot about these
ancient civilizations the character
stuff with the rossi crew continues to
be top-notch and the ending manages to
do all of them justice i don't know what
else there is to say other than you're
missing out on a lot of great story if
you don't read these books i do think
the best way to go about it is to start
at the beginning and not only because i
think it makes more sense that way i
think in this case the show and books
actually complement each other in a
really great way having the authors
working on both when you look at the
changes it just helps flesh out what
they were going for i'm sure it's
possible to start at book 7 if you've
watched the whole show but you will be a
little disoriented in the beginning and
that will compound the effect of the 30
year time jump doing it that way is
still better than not doing it though
and it's worth mentioning that the audio
books are great in this case because
jefferson maze does a fantastic job
reading them and they're easy to follow
since you're already familiar with most
of the characters from the show and i
think that feels like a good place to
leave things let me know in the comments
if you have any questions about the time
period between the series and if you
have any questions about the final three
books just make sure you mark those with
spoiler tags please like this video if
you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon